You can beat 99% of other businesses if
you only pick one thing to beat them on.
But there's four that you can compete
on. All right? And so that's what we're
going to talk about. The first of the
four vectors is speed. How do I do what
I'm going to do faster than everybody
else? Of the four vectors, I'm starting
with speed because I actually think it's
the most important of the four. And I
think the reason for that is that humans
learn behaviors with decreased latency.
meaning like Facebook and and and
Instagram or whatever you're watching
this on like has trained us to come back
not because they pay us to come back
because they have compressed latency for
some positive outcome and the positive
outcome they give us is a thumbs up.
They literally give us a little red
light and other people give actual money
but at a delay and they struggle to get
people to do things. So think about it
like this. You pay someone who works for
you every two weeks. It's much harder to
motivate them than if you actually paid
them in real time. And paying someone in
real time is actually so effective, it's
illegal. Truckers, for example, used to
be able to get paid per mile and like
almost essentially in real time. And so
they actually outlawed it because guys
would just keep driving to the point of
like insanity and wouldn't sleep for
days and it was unsafe. That's how
powerful speed is because that is what
trains behavior. functionally the
questions that we have to ask ourselves
is okay if speed is going to be my
competitive advantage it doesn't matter
what we do right there's components to
speed right so on one angle like you
have to think about each of these larger
vectors in smaller sub vectors for speed
it could be the distance between when
someone purchases and when they get
something right that's one vector of
speed the other vector is that if you're
doing something on a recurring basis how
much time is it going to take each time
so for example if I had a 10-minute
workout it's going to be more valuable
than an hourong workout if I could get
the same results If I say I'm going to
help someone get leads and I can help
them get those leads in an hour versus
waiting a week to turn on the ads,
that's more valuable, right? And so at
all times, it's always like, how can we
take what we're currently doing and do
it faster? And I can promise you, if you
just did that one thing compared to
everyone else in in your marketplace,
you just delivered faster, you'll have a
sustainable competitive advantage over
them and be able to charge premium
prices for it. What's really interesting
about speed is that speed rarely
actually costs more. It typically comes
from idea alpha, meaning like idea over
performance, like you've thought through
the process of their steps better than
the competition has. And as a result,
you actually can get better outcomes.
Now, part of this also comes down to
what types of customers you're picking.
If you have a hundred different types of
customers, it's very difficult to do
things quickly because you're doing lots
of different things for lots of
different people. This is why niching
down also helps you provide more value
because you're being more selective
about the customers you're picking. And
then as a result, you can be more
templatized in the in the types of
services and and and products that you
ultimately offer. And so there's kind of
three different vectors that I think
about uh in terms of like what can I
actually do to improve speed? Because
you're like, okay, I get that, but how
do I actually do it? So number one is I
want templates. All right, how can I
take what we're currently doing and make
these into templates? Can I have ad
templates? Can I have email templates?
Can I have landing page templates? Can I
have presentation templates? Can I have
at least templated steps that someone's
going to follow? Right? All of these are
just templates that we can pass on to
somebody else. Create a repeatable
process. If it's repeatable, they don't
have to decide. Decision-m is typically
the slowest part in the organization.
So, how do we remove all decisions to
speed up the time of completion? The
second one is pre-made. So, if you're in
physical products or even food, it's I
mean, fundamentally McDonald's changed
the game in fast food because they
started pre-making food. They already
had burgers on the line. So, when
someone ordered a burger, they just
handed it to them. And if you haven't
seen the movie Founder, great movie. He
experiences this and he's like, "No, no,
no. I I just ordered." And they're like,
"Yeah, that's your burger." And he's
like, "No, but I I just ordered." And
they're like, "Yeah, that's your
burger." And he's like, "Huh?" And it's
this big aha moment like, "Oh, this
changes everything." And so sometimes if
you know, there was a great Persian
place I used to go to. It crushes in
California. It's called Panini Cafe. Go
check it out. But they make amazing
Persian food. But one of the things I
realized is right as the lunch hour
started because I lived pretty close by
back then. They just started grilling
chicken because they knew that they were
about to get the lunch rush and they
knew that they were going to have people
who wanted juj kebab. Shout out for
those of you who know. All right. And so
they just thought ahead of time and it
became really vi because I would show up
and be like juj kebab extra rice my
whole thing. And they would just boom
they would deliver for me because they
didn't even have to make two order
because they just knew certain amounts
of things are always going to have
demand. And even if for some reason
someday they're not going to hit that,
the benefit they get of the vast
majority of their customers immediately
getting served and how many tables they
returned faster more than paid for the
small extra chicken that maybe they
didn't they had to throw out at the end
of the day. The third element here, and
this happens a lot with services, is
availability. Now, what does this mean?
I'll give you a couple examples. If you
have a spa or a salon or something, if
you have more availability for people to
book, it means they want something and
they can immediately get it faster. They
can get the appointment with you to get
their nails done, get their hair done.
Basically, the sooner you can have that
availability, the more you will be able
to convert and the more people will be
willing to pay. And so, if someone says,
"Hey, I have an appointment in 4 days or
I have an appointment in one day,"
they're probably far more likely to come
to you and be willing to pay more for
that one appointment. But how do you
increase availability? Sometimes it
means you have to pay people more or
extend their hours or hire more people.
But the reality is that this is one of
those things that is one of the largest
vectors in terms of increasing
throughput on a business that is
underappreciated by the vast majority of
business owners. And so when I invest in
a company or I look at a company a lot
of times I'm like oo like it's one of
the those huge hidden diamonds. I
probably shouldn't even share this but
it's one of those hidden diamonds that I
can almost always drive 20 30 40% more
through business by simply better
staffing the hours. Even at
acquisition.com we currently sell 12
hours a day, 7 days a week. And we're
now investing so we can get to 20 hours
a day because we have such a large
international market. We always want to
increase our availability because I know
the math behind this and it's a huge
impact on the bottom line. All right, so
the first vector, macro vector that you
can win on, and you only need one, but
if you have more than one, you just
dominate everyone. All right, is that we
went over speed. Now, the second is
risk. All right, so how can we make our
thing not risky? Now, think about
McDonald's, the example I gave you.
Well, they're both fast and they're not
risky. So, what does that actually mean?
Now, part of you are like, "Oh, no.
They're risky because of cancer and all
this other stuff." Well, well, let's
ignore that because why? Why do people
not care about this stuff? Actually,
it's funny. Speed. It's not latency. If
you ate a burger and immediately had
something growing on on on you, no one
would eat the burgers, but because it
happens 40 years from now, no one cares.
Speed changes behavior. And lack of
speed doesn't. So, what about risk? So,
a way you can translate risk is
reliability and consistency. It's a
different way of saying it, which is
when people buy, this is especially
important for services that are
recurring, where people get month after
month after month after month, they keep
coming back again and again and again.
And so the question is, how can we
consistently match conditions between
the perfect and ideal state and every
state that happens afterwards? And most
people dramatically underestimate the
amount of variables that exist in any
given encounter. And so as a result,
they have far less consistency than they
otherwise should. So that's just the
output. Now, what are the other
components of this? So I'll say one is
consistency. All right? In terms of
decreasing risk. Uh we could also
consider that reliability. If you say
you're gonna cut someone's grass, but
sometimes you're late or you uh show up
a different day or you don't show up one
week, like that's a major hit. People
just don't want to deal with that stuff.
Like they're not willing to. On the flip
side, if you're the type of guy where
someone's like, "You know what? I could
I could undercut your lawn care guy. You
know what? I could I could clean instead
of your cleaning person." A lot of
people are like, "You know what? I've
been with Rose for for 10 years and
she's never missed a day." You're like,
"I just I'm not willing to take the risk
because she's already paid down so
much." It's like, "But I could do for
20% less." It's like it's just not worth
it, right? That's real value that
actually defends the business. Now, what
other types of risk mitigation can we
offer? All right, one of them is
reputation, right? So, this is where
brand comes in. So, the consistency,
reliability typically happens after
someone makes a purchase. But how do we
how do we shift the perception to the
customer that they're going to have a a
high likelihood outcome that they're
going to get what they want? Well, one
of the easiest ways is that you've
gotten somebody else exactly what they
wanted and that person found out about
it. Now, if they don't know someone
directly, but then they just heard lots
of whispers, that's a reputation. You've
done it enough times for enough people
that you just have a reputation for
keeping your word, right? And a lot of
people, especially in the in the small
business space, especially especially in
their like response base, all of a
sudden sometimes their their their cost
to acquire customer goes up rapidly and
they're like, "What's going on? What's
happening?" But the thing is is that the
CPMs in your industry haven't gone up by
double or triple in that same period of
time. So, what is it? Is that your word
of mouth? People believe in positive
word of mouth. You think negative word
of mouth doesn't exist. Negative word of
mouth is like 10 times as viral as
positive. And somehow you think that
doesn't affect your sales. Of course it
affects your sales. People who would
have otherwise purchased choose not to
because of something they heard or read
online. And so one is okay. So we've got
reputation, we've got and we've got
consistency. So how do we do this? How
do we actually operationalize this? Now
I've talked a lot about guarantees. I
talked about in the offers book. All
right. Um and a lot of people took that
immediately like oh guarantees are the
only way that we reverse risk. It's just
one of the components. And I give that
to people because I assume that a lot of
people don't have a good reputation or
don't have a reputation at all or they
don't have enough customers to really
develop a process to become consistent.
But these two things are how you deliver
long-term risk mitigation. In the short
term, you do guarantees. Now again, and
I what's really interesting about this
is that everyone assumes that I was like
the guarantee guy, but like a lot of my
stuff that I sell has no guarantees,
right? But the thing is is that there's
four different types that I cover in the
book. All right? The first is
unconditional guarantees. When you're
starting out, that's a great way to do
it. Conditional guarantees. If you do
this and it doesn't happen, then I'll do
then I'll do why? What's my what's my
consideration, right? What am I going to
put on the table if you're going to put
this money on the table? And a lot of
times people mess this up. Guarantees
only work if you have stakes. So, if you
don't have reputation, you've got to
basically, it's literally like giving a
a payday loan. It's like you got to put
you got to take your watch off and be
like, "If you give me the money, I'll
put the watch down, right? You can take
my car if I don't pay this loan back."
It's the same idea just in business.
You're starting out. You're like,
"Here's my shirt. If I don't deliver
these leads or I don't deliver a great
back, you know, massage or I don't
deliver a good fitness experience, you
can take my shirt." Those are the first
two. There's two other types of
guarantees. There's implied and then
there's anti. All right? So, implied
guarantees is one of my favorite types
to use, which is just performance-based.
If you're good at what you do, winners
always want to compete on performance.
Think about your best salespeople. They
always want the most upside because
they're good. And so if you're actually
good, be willing to put it's another way
of putting skin in the game for you,
right? And so just put skin in the game.
And people are far more willing to take
risk if you take some risk for them. So
it's like we've got this big pile of
risk. How much are we going to eat down
versus the customer eating down? Now
here's the cool part is that you can
shrink that pile of risk over time with
reputation. Which brings up the fourth
guarantee, which is an anti-g guarantee,
which once you do have reputation and
you are consistent, you don't see
McDonald's saying, "We guarantee that
the burger is going to be good." You
just know it's going to be good, right?
Because you've had enough people. Now,
people are like, "Oh my god, McDonald's
is not good." Calm down. You get the
point from a business perspective. All
right? So, that's vector one is speed is
how can we do whatever we're doing
faster. Number two is risk. How can we
do it more consistently? How can we do
it more reliably? How can we and in so
doing build our reputation over time?
and that consistency and reliability.
How do I do that tactically? It's
actually looking at as many variables
that affect the condition or can affect
the outcome for the customer as humanly
possible and then actually trying to
control for all of them. So BF Skinner,
famous behavioral psychologist said if
many variables exist, many variables
must be studied. And so you might find
out so like for us to make videos, we
have like a hundred different little
golden BB's, little things that when put
together make a good video. And if we
just do 98, it's just a little bit less
good of a video. If we do 97, it's a
little bit less good of a video. And so
we just tried every time we learn a
little bit more, we add to that list.
Make another condition that we didn't
realize existed that mattered. We were
just talking about one right before I
did this video. So we did this big
filming session where I did a walk-in
talk and it was hot outside. So I took
my shirt off and I was doing it. It was
in Florida. It was super humid. And that
whole series of kind of like walking
talk things that I did murdered. It was
like some of my it was probably the
single best recording session I've ever
had in terms of performance of the clips
in the session. So, we're like, "Oh,
walk and talks work great." So, then I
did another series of walk-in talks
where I'm just like in normal clothes
because it wasn't it was actually cold
out. I think I put a jacket on and so I
put a jacket on in the second one and
literally I think it might have been the
actual worst recording session that I
ever had. What we got to see there is
that it wasn't the walk-in talk that was
the thing that made the shorts valuable.
It might have been me being shirtless,
which I have other considerations for,
which is like maybe maybe I'll start
only Alex someday. Uh but for now those
are the first two speed and risk or
risque if you will. Now the third one is
price. It's cheap right? So you can be
faster, you can be uh less risky or you
can be cheaper. Now we have a fourth one
too but let's talk about this for a
second. I tend to be the sell for more
more expensive guy. But you can win with
any of these three vectors. If people
absolutely know that your stuff's
amazing, they'll be willing to pay more
for it and they'll come to you instead
of somebody else. If you're the fastest,
they absolutely will come to you over
other people because you can deliver on
all these vectors of speed. If you're
the cheapest, people will absolutely
come to you. Like to pretend that price
doesn't matter is silly. Of course price
matters but so does value because value
is a sorry the the deal rather is the
comparison between price what you
pay and what you get right and so
something is appropriately cheap if you
get tremendous value for a low price but
the answer is not hearing this and
saying oh I will now lower my price that
is certainly a terrible decision but
instead it's day one deciding our
competitive advantage the moat that
we're going to build around is being
cheaper than everyone else. And you have
to start that way day one. That means
every component of the business from
click to close to delivered is organized
such that you can pass on as much of
that cost-saving to the customer. And
so, for example, um if you were like,
hey, I want to start a you know, a
marketing agency for small business
owners. Well, in general, typically a
pretty bad business. Why? Because it
turns out really high. Their volatility
reflects onto you with an exception. If
you can make the services cheap enough,
I have seen it work well, but I mean way
cheaper than you think. I'm talking $100
to $300 a month for services that most
people charge $2,000 a month for. When
you can do that, now you have something
that a lot of people are interested in.
So that even on their worst day of
business, they're like, "Well, I'm not
going to cancel that." Like, it's it's
only a hundred bucks, only 200 bucks,
and it certainly makes way more than
that even on my worst month. Right? And
to the same degree we there basically
okay if I want to do this right if
you're you like okay how do I actually
build for cheapness all right so there's
three ways that I think about this so
number one is you can have AI right day
one now a lot of you guys should be
already be investing this stuff like for
sure AI is giving the best employees 10x
the leverage they had before and so if
there's ever been a time to have to pay
people better it's been today because AI
is now taking your best person making it
10 times as effective so it's like why
would you not like you're always like
man if I could have 10 10 John's or 10
Daniels or 10 10 Michaels, man, that
would be amazing. It's like, well, AI is
giving you 10 Michaels and so be willing
to pay the Michaels of your business
more because you actually do get more
from them now more than ever. So, number
one is AI. The second is I'll just say
automation because I think automation
for some reason has like been forgotten
about. Um, there's still lots of stuff
that can get automated that doesn't
necessarily have AI, but you build day
one with those automations in place.
Now, the third is offshoring, right? or
near shoring basically paying
significantly less for the same labor,
but you're actually making this your
entire business strategy from day one.
We are going to win by being the
cheapest. And if that's you, then you
state that first and foremost in your
marketing, in your sales. And what's
really cool about it is typically when
you're the cheapest, the sales are
pretty easy. Uh marketing is not that
hard. The difficulty is being
profitable. But I've seen some
tremendously profitable businesses that
structure themselves from day one on
being the cheapest. And a little little
tidbit, a little pro tip that I think a
lot of business owners are going to miss
out on. I think people are not are not
getting this. If you do all this stuff,
let's say you do the offshoring, you do
the automation to the eye. You don't
need to tell your customers. You can
just have AI automation and offshoring
into your business and you just sell a
normal service. You don't need to tell
them you have a bunch of VAS in the
Philippines. You don't need to tell them
that a lot of your stuff is from AI.
Don't say, "Hey, we're an AI design
firm." Just be a design firm and then
charge the same rates or a good deal for
design because you just have an
automated backend. Great. Amazing. So,
that will allow you to get more cash
flow in the business and ultimately
provide more value. All right. So, three
vectors so far. Speed, how do I do it
faster than anybody else in the market?
Risk, how do I do it more reliably and
build a reputation better than anyone
else in the market? Cost, how do I do it
cheaper, consistently, and still be
profitable than anyone else in the
market? And finally, you have ease. Now,
before I dive into these, I want to make
this point. If you just win on one of
these, you can have an incredibly
successful business. If you can do
multiple vectors, then you'll crush
everyone. Real quick, check this out.
So, if you aren't sure what strategic
competitive advantage you should be
doubling down on, um, I'd love to invite
you out to one of our scaling workshops
uh, that we have here in Vegas at our
headquarters and my team can actually
work with you on it. But before you do
that, you can download our free $100
million scaling roadmap um where you can
plug in information and it will give you
basically your step where you're at in
the scaling process and ultimately give
you the things you can help get to the
next level. But like I said, if you want
help from my team, you can book a call
after you download this. It's free and
we'd love to uh see if we can help you
out. A quote that I like is the best for
the most people for the least. And so
best probably takes into account speed
and ease um and risk. And for the most
it's going to be like total number of
people that it helps. And then for the
least, right? It's like and I've had
different one like unique expensive
sticky air. How do I do something that
no one else can do? How do I have it
that they keep buying it? How do I have
it that I have high gross margins? And
how do I have it so it's over and over
and over again? Right? So we think about
these little monikers. I think about
this when I'm trying to build a business
because ultimately these are the ways
that you win. These are the strategic
modes. So people talk about strategy,
but fundamentally it's going to have to
ladder up to one of these things. So if
you're like, "Oh, by the way, what's
acquisition.coms, it's going to be this
one probably primarily and then I would
say secondary vectors are these. We're
obviously not cheapest, right? And so
that's where I've built my business
around. Now, if I had a different now,
not all the business, our portfolio are
are built that way, right? We have a a
teeth whiting chain that's more around
speed, ease, and cheapness, right? And
so you get like you have to make sure
that the strategy is is best tailored to
the customer after you're trying to
serve. All right, let's talk about ease.
I want to make a big point about ease.
If you want to make your product more
convenient for customers, you don't make
something convenient because we want to
like I want to do something to my
product. It's actually the opposite,
which is why I think most products suck.
You make something easier by removing
everything that is no longer required.
You make something easy by saying what
is what is hard about this and then
removing everything that's hard. And so
what's cool about this process is all
like like easy is not the outcome. It's
removing all hard and then easy happens
as a consequence. Right? So like easy is
not noticeable. It's like good design.
It should vanish. Right? Like if you
look at an iPhone, an iPhone is the
result of what happens when you remove
everything that sucks about a phone and
what remains is an iPhone. The the UX
vanishes into the screen. There's no
menus. You just hit what you need. It
immediately opens up. Right? This is how
we have to think about ease. And so this
happens for services. It happens for
products. And just like I was saying
earlier with if many variables exist,
many variables must be studied. And the
nice thing is that customers will tell
you what's what's hard thing number one,
what's hard thing number two, what's
hard number three, what's hard thing
number four. And you have that list. And
then the way that you make something
easy is one at a time crossing things
out one at a time until eventually
people are like, "Man, this thing just
works." And that takes work. Take a
thing, figure out what makes it hard,
remove all those pieces, and then what
you're left with is something that's
easy. This is the work. And I wish I
could say this in a hundred different
ways, but like honestly, that's the
game. And so when we're thinking about
this, it's like as a c like you want to
think again, click to close to
delivered. So when a customer is coming
into your ecosystem into your world, how
much information do they need to give?
Do they have to give information the
same information on multiple calls? Are
we passing calls between reps? Like I'll
give you a really simple example. So
right now you probably have like if you
have a business that that sells via
appointments, right? You have phone
calls, you have people manning the
calls. If you have multiple calls that
occur in order for someone to buy, let
me tell you what happens all the time.
Call one, tell me about your business.
All right, tell me about the size of the
business. Tell me about some
qualification. Blah blah blah. Okay,
cool. So then let me set you up with
Charlie. Charlie will get you set up.
Okay, cool. Now we get on the phone with
Charlie. Three days later. Charlie's
like, "Hey, how's it going? What's the
revenue of the business? What's the size
of the business? What's the You're like,
"Dude, I just I just told the Why am I
Why am I telling I hate you already?"
Right? And so instead of doing that, let
me show you the thing is that this is a
very binary outcome. This is a very
binary one. A lot of them aren't. A lot
of them are more continuous, but this is
binary. And the only thing easier than
doing what I'm about to share with you
is not doing it, which is why most
people don't. your salespeople, your
setters, or your sales people in general
should take notes on the customers. And
here's what's cool. If you start the
second call and say, "Hey, had a
conversation with Charlie. Charlie told
me that your revenue is this, your
industry is this, and the biggest issue
you're dealing with is this. Does that
sound about right?" They're going to be
like, "Wow, they actually did some
homework. This is a pretty buttoned up
operation. You know what? That just made
it easier." And so, we have to think
about every single little step. That's
just that's just the sale. And if you
don't think that how you sell affects
their perception of the quality of
service that you have, you are kidding
yourself. Many people will make a
judgment based on how good your product
is, based on how good your sales motion
is, how clean it is, how dial it is. If
you call someone in 30 seconds, they're
like, "Man, these guys are on it." They
would imagine that if you make a promise
about speed later, guess what? The past
experience they have that they're going
to use as judgment is on the sales
process. And so this again I'm just
talking about sales because everyone
like you know everybody likes talking
about sales but um well I like talking
about sales fine caught me. Uh on the
flip side is the back end is the same
thing. What's the onboarding call look
like? What are the activation points?
What are the touch points with the
customer? What kind of reporting are we
going to provide to them so they know
that we're we're delivering them value?
What things do we give? We're giving
massage. We giving a map where we show
them where the pain is and we show them
hey when they come back in this is where
you said last time you were in pain.
How's that on a scale from 1 to 10
today? Wow that was really good. Like I
mean, can you imagine you walk into a
massage place you've been to before and
they're like, "Oh, last time you
struggled with your shoulder." And the
reason that so many people like just
going with the same person is because
the business have so few processes. And
so it's like, well, I might as well just
go with the same masseuse because she
knows me. But if every masseuse or
massager, I don't know, the male
version, whatever, massager, uh, already
knew the pain that you were dealing with
beforehand. Could you imagine what a
superior experience that would be as a
company? And then also, how much more
would you be able to keep customers?
Whereas when the masseuse leaves, they
take all the customers that went with
them. Not very sticky. But if every
massage person knew all the pain points
of the business, that would make it
easier. Easy is when everything that's
hard vanishes. And that's all that's
left is the value. If you're looking at
these four, how can I do it faster? How
can I make it more reliable? How can I
do it cheaper? How can I make it easier
for the customer? The end state, the the
kill shot is that you have all four.
Now, to have all four, it almost always
has to be tech. Now, you can typically
have three of the four if you have
labor. All right? So, if you have a
service based business, you're basically
going to need to pick three. But
specifically, you need to make sure you
have one. Now, why why am I so hard on
this one thing? Well, customers do not
understand multiple benefits. Now, they
can like from a messaging perspective.
Now, when they buy something and they
experience it, that's different. But
from a marketing angle, if you say,
"Hey, we're the fastest, we're the least
risky, and we're the easiest," it's too
much. Just focus on the core vector. And
if you're like, which one do I pick?
Pick the one that values the most to
your customer. Pick to the one that they
care about the most. And so if you know
that your people care the most about
speed, then speed's the speed's the
angle. If there's a huge cost when
something doesn't go well with a
business, then risk is the angle, right?
Or the customer, whatever, right? And if
and if it's just in general a huge pain
to do this thing, then how can I make it
easy? So I'll tell you, there's a
there's a lady that I know in
Albuquerque, New Mexico that I used to
um that I used to go to church with when
I went to church. and she had a massive
business in in in New Mexico. And her
entire business was built on one thing,
speed and ease. She had a DMV business
where she just privatized getting people
their IDs. That was it. That's all it
was. And I remember her talking to me
and she was like, "Yeah, they just
passed a new law that everybody uh in
New Mexico has to get a new ID because
we just changed the license." And she
was like, "Well, that's uh, you know, 12
million people times 50
bucks." And I just remember her saying
that. I was like, "How elegant, right?"
And the thing is is that her $50 is like
she was able to get people in and out in
15 minutes from the time they walked in
the door to the time they left. Could
you imagine how lovely of an experience
that would be? Everybody when they think
about getting their idea right now, it's
like just pain. All you think is just
like waste of a day, just frustration,
dealing with inept people who have no
urgency, no regard for other people, and
just generally deal with you as a
nuisance. Like you're somehow
inconveniencing them in their day of not
working that you have disrupted their
day of not working by existing and
breathing on them, right? Of course you
hate them. And so she just had a
business not hard to beat, right? When
that's the standard. Again, there are
industries that are like this that are
privatized that still no one tries to
compete in. And so if you want to get
into a new space or you already have a
business and you're like, "How do I
actually win? I feel like I'm the same
as everybody else." Pick one and
dominate. And so if you're wondering
which of these do I pick? Obviously, you
start with the customer reverse
backwards. But let's do the DMV example
I just said. Is she going to win on
being cheaper than the government? No.
I'm pretty sure it's free or it's a
nominal price in order to get the new
the new IDs. And so she's not going to
win on cheap. But what could what else
could she win on? Speed, ease. In other
ways, the ease can also be like positive
customer experience. Like those are
things that improve the overall
experience for the customer. She could
could she double her prices? I'll bet
you plenty of people probably be willing
to pay $100 to not have to waste a day,
right? So she doesn't have to win on
this, right? So she has to pick the one
that that now risk. I mean, as long as
you get the idea, I mean, you have to be
good enough at this, right? But she's
going to work on her reputation by being
having a reputation of being faster and
easier, right? And so if you're trying
to pick one, you pick the one that's
going to matter most to the customer.
And if you are competing in a space that
has a lot of cheap or sometimes even
free competitors, just remember this
fast beats free. So back in the day,
there was Napster, which some of you
guys may have remembered. It's probably
before actually probably half of y'all's
time. Uh there's something called Lime
Wire that happened later. Uh there was
Kazah, there was all these different uh
basically sharewware things where you
could share files with one another and
ultimately just like steal music for
free. I'll just be honest. That's what
it was. Right. So when that was
happening, how did a company like
Spotify come in not really free um and
beat them? They won on speed and they
went on risk because when you downloaded
Lime Wire, you knew that you were
downloading all sorts of viruses to your
computer, number one. And then number
two on Spotify, it was like it was just
you just picked the song, you could
immediately start listening to it. And
so they beat an industry that was
literally free by being faster. And I
remember when I uh when I went to get
Chipotle once, this was at University of
Maryland. I was visiting the campus. And
it has I think it's like the number one
highest grossing Chipotle in like the
nation. This thing is packed. It's in
the middle of like the the Commons or
whatever, right? And it was happened to
be Halloween, the weekend that I went to
visit. You can imagine. And so at
Halloween for Chipotle, they do this
thing where if you wear any kind of
foil, you dress up like a burrito, they
like give you free burritos, whatever.
And I didn't know, I didn't think that
that was the day that I wanted to go
have Chipotle. So I walk up and I'm
like, "Oh." And it was it was imagine a
grocery store parking lot. So massive
parking lot. There's a twot there. The
line stretched through the entire
parking lot. It was insane. And I just
remember thinking to myself when I got
there and I was like, I would pay $20 to
just have the burrito that I want and
not have to wait in this line even if
it's free. And that was the moment where
I cinched that that that that concept.
Fast beats free. So if you're not sure,
start with the customer, reverse
backwards, look at the competitive
landscape. You probably one of these one
of these four vectors or maybe more. If
you guys are like, "Man, this is so
good." Let me tell you a cool little
secret. If this just feels true, you're
like, "This is so true." Guess why it's
so
true? Because these four are the value
equation. So your risk is your perceived
like achievement. Your ease is your
effort and sacrifice. Your speed is your
time delay. And then your your your
cheaper is going to be ultimately the
dream outcome. Those are the elements of
value. And so all that is I put
different words around something that is
these are the core elements of value.
And because they're the core elements of
value, those are the things you have to
translate to your customer in your
marketing as your one defining winning
angle. And if you haven't picked the
book, you can go grab it. Um it's free
on my podcast and it's on Amazon and you
can probably find it wherever you search
it. Hey, if you like this video, you
might like this video uh because it's
similar to this one, except even more
awesome.